مراس الجزيره في بغداد عامر ينضم الينا
مباشره من هناك عامر هل هل من بيانات
اضافيه هل من تفاصيل متعلقه بطبيعه
الاستهداف وايضا ربما الخسائر
نعم نشوان يعني لا يوجد حتى الان بيان
رسمي وصلنا بخصوص ما جرى لكن هناك الكثير
حتى الان من التصريحات التي تتحدث عن هذا
الانفجار الذي سمع بشكل واضح في مختلف
مناطق بغداد هذا الانفجار ال الذي استهدف
احد مقرات الدعم اللوجستي للحشد الشعبي
هنا في شرق العاصمه بغداد المكان ايضا مهم
لعده اعتبارات نعم مقر الحشد الشعبي وهي
وهو تعلم انه عباره عن احد اذرع الرسميه
في الجيش العراقي التابعه لقياده الاركان
الامر الاخر والمهم ان هذا المكان قريب
جدا من مبنى وزاره الداخليه يبعد تقريبا 2
م عن هذا المبنى الحديث حتى الان عن مقتل
شخصين وان هذين الشخصين هم قاده بارزين في
حركه النجباء المنضوي
تحت الجيش العراقي وايضا المقاومه
العراقيه تعلم بان العديد من فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه ومنذ بدايه الحرب على
غزه وهي تعلن عن استهدافها المستمر للعديد
من القواعد الامريكيه سواء هنا في العراق
في شمال العراق وفي وسط العراق وحتى
القواعد الامريكيه في سوريا وبالتالي طبعا
كثير من البيانات التي تسمع وتصدر بشكل
متتالي عن هذه الاستهدافات وان هذه
الاستهدافات هي دعم ل اهل غزه دعم للحرب
التي تجري في غزه وانها ستتوقف عندما
تتوقف هذه الحرب على غزه وكل هذه البيانات
تتحدث عن استمرار هذه الاستهدافات هذا
الاستهداف الامريكي على ما يبدو حتى الان
لا يوجد تصريح طبعا رسمي امريكي لكن نحن
نبني هنا على الاستهدافات السابقه لانه
هذا اي نشوان ليس الاستهداف الاول هناك
تقريبا هذا ربما الثالث او الرابع حتى
الان الذي يتم فيه استهداف مقرات للحشد
الشعبي في داخل العراق ردا على ما يبدو
على استهداف القواعد الامريكيه في العراق
وفي سوريا وبالتالي يرجح كثير من
المراقبين هنا ان يكون هذا الاستهداف قد
تم بطائرات مسيره امريكيه استهدفت هذا
المقر وهو كما ذكرنا مقر في شارع فلسطين
في شرق العاصمه العراقيه وك في السابق مقر
للجنه الاولمبيه في السابق لكن حركه
النجباء حولته ل مقر للدعم اللوجستي
والحديث كما ذكرنا حتى الان عن مقتل شخصين
وهما على ما يبدو قاده بارزين في حركه
النجباء بالاضافه الى اصابه خمسه اشخاص
لكن نحن طبعا بانتظار اي بيانات رسميه
تصدر لتوضيح ما الذي جرى بالضبط في هذا
المكان ومن المتهم بتنفيذ هذه الهجمات ا